yeah what's going on Eddie nothing much
yeah just enjoying the summertime yeah
beautiful out it's really nice
especially this week the weather broke
it's not it's kind of hot today but yeah
it's been pretty nice so far in the
Northeast we can't complain and actually
it got us thinking here at the TV show
that we should do something on the
program to try and get outside yeah you
know and Annie and I were talking we
thought we should go somewhere take the
show outside but we didn't know where to
go this was a problem for us we're not
really big with ideas no we're not we're
not we're liking the it's not we're
idiots yeah yeah and so we were thinking
you know what to do and then we had this
idea which was let's let fate intervene
so we thought wouldn't it be cool if we
just took out a map of the tri-state
area and just threw a dart at it and
wherever that map lands Andy and I would
go there and see what's going on with
this is kind of a cool thing
yeah and just you know tape the whole
thing while we're going exactly road
trip exactly so just a couple days ago
Andy and I did just that and this is
what happened we've set up a map of the
New York tri-state area it's a 75-mile
radius map it starts right from
Manhattan and we've blindfolded Andy
here Andy can you see anything no okay
good Andy has a dart wherever that dart
lands that's where we're going so I'll
turn him three times one two three
that's great perfect dart please Andy
thank you
okay it looks like it's nearest to south
central South Centreville here we come
[Applause]
we're speeding out of Manhattan and
we're on a road trip we have no idea
where our travels are gonna take us no
idea take the blindfold off yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and II guess what what speed limits 55
guess what I'm doing oh my god 6363 pal
rock and roll
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well South Centreville I don't really
have anything exactly for South Senate
bill petrovin no sir
oh you know so son can we talk to you
for just a second is there gambling or
no hyaline mm-hmm is there a movie
theater there no is there a custard ice
cream stand or
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
throw a lot of manure right now you
can't smell this at home unless you're
watching this show with Grandpa
wait look up here Andy there's a sign
Centreville yeah this is I think the
main street right here
South Center this is this is it this is
the financial district oh I do a lot of
shopping so what's your name sir Frank
what are the people like in South Center
bill oh they're real friendly people if
you had to describe the town in a few
words how would you describe it
no no police here Polly oh no just the
state peaceful state yeah but they don't
come by off and do that no
so this town's are pretty easy mark
isn't it Andy let's get to work I'm
sorry Sara can you take us for a spin
around the yard yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
by your house here we come on in
it's very much to do what what would you
recommend we do here in skin in Senate
bill in here there's absolutely nothing
except to please what we do play
basketball play football and go swimming
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
position the Jets Oh
[Music]
meat of a family your name is Mike Mike
good to see you probably know under the
barn calves in there and this is where
you do the milking yeah
do you milk them by hand no no I got
machines Oh the machines but where's all
the utter things that you strap on right
in here so just take a look at that
that's beautiful it's great from the
utter that is really good like the best
milk I've ever had my heart
[Music]
and I threw it darted the map we didn't
know where it was gonna land it landed
in the town we'd never heard of called
South Centreville we didn't know what
we'd find what we found was hospitality
good cheer nice people and a couple of
cows over that way the point is this
we're very happy that we came here we're
glad to be your friends and we'd like
now to leave you this flag that will
stand here on the town green you see it
it's got one side as the show logo the
other side is Conan and Andy at their
best and this flag we hope will stand
here forever to remind you and remind
anyone who comes that South Centreville
is a place of good love and good cheer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time
all right we're gonna take a little
break
we got a great show tonight Brendan
Fraser's on the program DB sweeney
coming up we got a lot of show we'll see
missed a bit